- So y'all are new.
And I was gonna say, DeWanda,
I love your character.
I was like, oh, she gonna be badass.
I was like very excited about it.
Did you love like becoming a part of this?
- Yeah. It's, to your point, I mean,
it's the greatest franchise of all time.
And I just feel really
fortunate that I was back
in this beyond epic way,
bringing back the legacy characters.
I just, I feel very, very grateful.
- Yeah.
And Mamoudou, this is your
first time doing this too.
So like, what was it
like to be a part of it?
- It was nuts.
- Is it kind of intimidating?
'Cause you're walking on
set and you're like, okay.
- Yeah, my first set was so
Laura and Sam and you know
I grew up with them watching.
This was the first big blockbuster movie
I ever saw as a kid.
So to see them and I admire them as actors
forever as a kid and as an adult.
To see them as those characters
and work opposite them,
I constantly found myself
just like, wait, am I,
am I really here?
Is this a real thing?
But they really made
it just so comfortable
and a really pleasant
experience, as did these guys.
- Yeah.
- Oh, that's awesome.
So DeWanda, did Chris give you any advice?
You know, it's an action movie
and he's in a lot of action movies.
- He had a lot of tips.
No, he had every tip.
I keep trying to get him to teach a class
on how to be an action hero.
- [Kelly] He's so good.
(Chris laughs)
- [DeWanda] Okay, I just need to--
- [Bryce] And he spreads the wealth.
- He spreads the wealth.
Okay, no, let's talk through this.
I'm glad this image is here.
Now I can talk through this.
Okay, okay, okay, all right, great.
So, Pratt was legit like
he was like, all right,
so the camera's this way,
your arm can't be back here.
It needs to be angled right here.
- Oh, it's like choreography.
- It is choreography.
All right.
It is like the level of specificity,
the knee bend, everything about it.
I just, I think you're the most
brilliant human being ever.
- Awww.
- Just very generous.
- Thank you.